Hi ihr Lieben!
Na, wie sieht's aus?
Neujahr, macht ihr jetzt auch so eine Ernährungsumstellung oder möchtet ihr euch gesünder ernähren?
Oder vielleicht so den Winterspeck ein bisschen abtrainieren?
Dann hab ich heute eine super Idee für euch,
was ihr zum Mittagessen kochen könnt, was gesund ist,
lange satt hält und eben perfekt ist, falls ihr jetzt eben die Ernährung so ein bisschen
umstellen möchtet und es ist auch sehr stark angefragt.
Also das ganze letzte Jahr über wurde immer wieder gefragt:
"Kiki kannst du mal  gesunde Rezepte machen?"
Natürlich gab's zwischendurch mal gesunde Rezepte aber heute -
ich bin super gespannt, wie das Video ankommt -
heute gibt's wirklich meine Nonplusultra Gemüsepfanne, die ich selber
immer total gerne mache.
Und hier sind jetzt, die Zutaten, die sind auch nicht schwer einzukaufen,
die gibt's überall.
Hier haben wir Kokosmilch und Öl, da nehmt ihr gern neutrales Öl.
Hier vorne hab ich Gemüse. Heute nehm' 'ich Zucchini, Möhren, Paprika.
Hier hab ich noch eine Knoblauchzehe, dazu sag ich euch gleich was.
Außerdem was bei mir nie fehlen darf, ich liebe Brokkoli!
Hab ich hier schon gewaschen. Und an Gewürzen Kurkuma, Curry,
dann hab ich hier edelsüßes Paprikapulver, scharfe Paprikaflocken,
Kreuzkümmel und natürlich Salz und Pfeffer.
Und es geht auch schon los!
Das Gemüse könnt ihr auf jeden Fall bevor ihr die Pfanne erhitzt noch vorbereiten.
Das heißt schön klein schnibbeln, ich nehm' dafür jetzt meinen Wellenschneider,
dann sieht das am Ende auch richtig hübsch aus.
Und dann geh ich an die Pfanne, erhitze den Herd, ich lasse erstmal Knoblauch dünsten
also Knoblauch nie richtig heiß braten sondern wirklich nur auf mittlerer
Stufe dünsten zusammen mit dem Öl.
Und danach geb ich das Gemüse dazu und nochmal ganz kurz zum Knoblauch:
das ist heute ein Weltwunder, ich hab nur eine kleine Knoblauchzehe im
Kühlschrank gehabt! Sonst hab ich immer Knoblauch da, ich liebe Knoblauch!
Also euch schreib ich in die Videobeschreibung, dass ihr 2
Knoblauchzehen reinnehmen sollt. Fände ich persönlich jetzt heute auch besser.
So! Jetzt hab ich das hier schon erledigt und gebe jetzt das Gemüse dazu
und das könnt ihr dann ganz einfach 3 Minuten lang
auch so ein bisschen andünsten.
So jetzt kommt der letzte Schritt, meine Lieben.
Kokosmilch dazugeben, die Gewürze dazu und dann zusammen mit dem Deckel
einfach nur so ungefähr 7-8 Minuten lang köcheln lassen.
Vorausgesetzt ihr habt euer Gemüse auch in mundgerechte Stücke geschnitten.
Da müsst ihr einfach mal schauen, wie dick oder wie dünn das ist
und ob es dann auch wirklich gar ist.
Und fertig ist die gesunde Gemüsepfanne - in 10min zubereitet.
Und macht dazu am allerbesten Reis, der passt nämlich wirklich total gut dazu.
Ich mach ganz normalen Reis, ihr könnt aber auch gern den türkischen Reis nehmen
von mir, verlink ich euch in die Videobeschreibung genauso wie
alle Zutaten natürlich, alle Mengenangaben. Alle Utensilien,
die ich benutzt hab, die ihr bei mir im Shop findet.
Und schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare: Was möchtet ihr als nächstes sehen?
Soll es wieder eine Torte werden oder wieder was gesundes?
Wieder Mittagessen Inspiration? (H: Alles!)
Schreibt's mir auf jeden Fall rein, bestimmt schreiben ganz viele "alles"!
Schreibt's mir auf jeden Fall gerne rein, ich richte mich da super, super gerne nach euch.
Ansonsten lasst es euch schmecken, es ist wirklich total köstlich.
Das bekommt ihr teilweise wirklich in Restaurants für 12-13€ serviert.
Genau das! (H: Ja das wollt ich dir grad sagen)  Oder?
Haben wir damals auch oft bestellt aber macht's einfach zuhause!
So jetzt ganz...(H: Viel Spaß!)
Viel Spaß! Kurzen Blackout gehabt!
So, guten Appetit und wir sehen uns bei meinem nächsten Rezeptvideo!
Tschüss ihr Lieben! (H:Und nicht vergessen, zu abonnieren und zu liken!)
Da-das, also hör mal! *stammelt*
*beide lachen*